hello and welcome to cloud on air from
Google cloud we are hosting webinars
every Tuesday
my name is deep dish or Vaslav and I'll
be talking to you today about cloud
spanner and how it works you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and we
have Googler standing by to answer them
and I'll also take some questions after
the the presentation part is over so
let's get started
so cloud spanner we've talked about a
few other webinars as well but today we
wanted to take a deeper dive into how we
get eventual sorry global external
consistency with this system with asset
transactions and good performance so
let's do a little recap in case you're
joining us for the first time of what
cloud spanner is so here's a suite of
our managed database and storage
services on Google cloud platform so as
you can see we have a wide array of
services to meet all needs of your
applications form the storage and
database standpoint we have cloud
storage which is our binary or object
store you know we have our key value
stored in memcache App Engine and then
we have a datastore and cloud BigTable
which are witches are non relational
offerings and on the relational side we
have cloud sequel and cloud spanner
which is our scale out our relational
database service and on the other end we
have bigquery which is our enterprise
data warehouse so you know with cloud
span and cloud bigquery we have the full
suite of sort of scale out relational
database as well as scale out enterprise
data warehouse so what is cloud spanner
really so it's the only enterprise grade
globally distributed and strongly
consistent managed database service
built for the cloud specifically to
combine the benefits of relational
database structure and non-relational
horizontal scale what does that mean so
basically we
cloudspinner you don't have to make
trade-offs you can get schemas asset
transactions across rows regions and
continents a lot along with sequel
querying so not something that sort of
resembles sequel but actual sequel with
an 2011 sequel Compliance a query engine
and you get the benefits of a
horizontally scalable no sequel system
so you we offer up to five nines of
availability and that's a lot of nines
but what that really means is we
guarantee less than five minutes of
downtime a year which is
industry-leading for the SLA it is a
fully managed and easily scalable
service so what that means is you can
within with a few clicks you can deploy
a globe spanning database and be ready
to go so let's get into how we are able
to achieve this no trade off
industry-leading system so what is the
foundation on which were established so
first of all as you can see here Google
cloud platform has a number of regions
and more coming in fact we added like
something like 39 zones last year alone
and we continue to invest in the
platform and in the infrastructure for
our customers so as I said we added 39
new zones and we continue to add more
and as you can see you know we have data
centers and zones across the world to
provide services close to where the
customers are and where the applications
need to be for our customers to provide
the best application performance to
their their end-users now on this
platform we are we have built cloud
spanner instances so we have instances
in two flavors there are regional cloud
spanner instances and multi region
instances so in this case with regional
cloud spanner as you can see we are
available in multiple regions on GCP
across the world and we're adding more
read
as we go in fact our aim is to basically
be part of the initial footprint on all
regions and moving forward as as we
launch more regions on GCP what this
means is that we have replicated instant
like basically we have three zones that
are replicating inside each region so if
you have data locality or data
governance concerns then with cloud
spanner regional instances you can put
your entire data base in one region and
the data remains in that region the
other flavors I talked about is multi
region configurations and the the first
one we are talking about here is a
continental monthly region so as you can
see there are two data centers where the
cloud spanner configuration exists which
means there are five zones across those
two data centers that support the
databases you create in that instance
then there is a multi region global
instance which is North America Europe
and Asia so here what's important to
note is that when we when we look at the
green bounding box for both the regional
and the multi region sorry the the
regional single continent and multi
continent configurations that you're
really talking to one cloud spanner
database and that one database is being
replicated across the zones and regions
as we talked about here but that's
transparent to you so in this case we
have replicas across nine zones in the
four regions that are marked here for
the North America Europe and Asia
configuration and for you you talk to
one cloud spanner database that is
transparently replicated across those
nine zones but you never have to choose
which zone to go to or which replica to
talk to that's something that the API
takes care of now that's about like the
physical location of the data but how is
that data talk or connected right how
are those data centers that GCP has how
their zones and regions connected so as
you know or you may have heard of
oh cloud has its own network in fact
Google built its own networking fabric a
while ago and continues to invest in it
which means that we connect our data
centers and we want to put requests and
user traffic on our network as quickly
as possible which is different from
other cloud providers because usually
they have to deal with the hot potato
problem where if their network gets
congested they offload to the public
Internet
whereas in Google's case we actually
want to put your requests on our network
as quickly as possible because we have
built the network to be redundant we
have multiple you know links to the same
place or multiple routes to the to the
same two connection points and you know
we've built the stack up to be resilient
and highly performant so we can predict
Layton sees across these different
endpoints and therefore we can give
better performance and we don't have to
rely on the routing constraints and
Layton sees of the public Internet in
most cases and as I was talking about
earlier let's go into the hot potato
problem so basically what a typical
cloud provider does is they try to
offload user traffic to the public
Internet as quickly as possible because
you know they don't have as much a
bandwidth provision so in most cases you
know that the network gets congested
especially as they're new especially if
there's you know higher traffic volumes
that are happening so as soon as that
happened this lot of people are asking
for the same data across the same data
points endpoints then the the traffic
gets offloaded to the public internet
which has you know its own congestion
problems and its own sort of traffic
issues so there isn't predictable
performance and latency in that case but
with Google Cloud and with Google in
general we try to put user traffic as
quickly as possible on the Google
network so that as I said we have built
the stack very carefully so that we can
predict performance for the network in
this case and therefore can offer good
performance and predictable agencies to
the customers of Google Cloud
now let's get into the specifics of
cloud spanner itself so there are
multiple concepts that you may have come
across with cloud spanner there is nodes
replicas and the data that lives in
cloud spanner
so with cloud spanner you you buy nodes
and you get storage right and they scale
independently so you can keep adding
data to cloud spanner you can keep
writing data to your database and you
know the storage will automatically
scale to absorb that data and the the
compute for that database is coming from
the nodes that you provision that's
something you have to provision and it's
a few clicks that you go to the UI to
our console and then just you know add
nodes and within a few seconds to a
minute or a few minutes you get the
additional nodes and then the data is
automatically sharded across those new
nodes which means you don't have to take
care of you know physical provisioning
obviously but you also don't have to
take care of the data sharding and
rebalancing that's something the cloud
spanner takes care of the system takes
care of itself
so let's get into the concepts of how
these things work and differ from each
other so let's talk about the regional
configuration first so as I mentioned
before cloud spanner is replicated
across multiple zones either within a
region or in the multi region case
across multiple zones in multiple GCP
regions so in the regional configuration
we have three replicas that are in three
different availability zones within a
single GCP region so in this case we're
looking at let's say European region one
which has availability zones a B and C
within which a cloud spanner instance
will exist so when you go to the console
and create a cloud spanner instance and
you choose a regional configuration any
regional configuration it will come with
three availability zones within which
your instance will exist and all the
data and all the databases that you
create within that instance will be
replicated in this configuration and as
you can see here there are three
readwrite replicas
in the three available reasons now going
to a more interesting picture let's look
at our global configuration which is at
Arnhem your Asia one configuration that
we looked at earlier in this case as I
had mentioned earlier there are nine
replicas across three different
continents and nine different
availability zones so in this particular
case if you notice the right quorum has
five replicas that are all in the US in
North America in this case and there are
two replicas each in Asia and Europe for
read-only workloads so the way to think
about the multi reading configurations
is that you're trading off right latency
a little bit higher light right latency
for very low read latency close to your
clients and users so data from cloud
spanner is always going to be served
from the closest healthiest replicas
that it can satisfy the request that the
user has made and in this case yes all
right requests go to the US and we'll
get into that but because we have our
network that I talked about that has
predictable low latency Xand is
redundant and has multiple routes to two
different endpoints because of that we
can actually offer pretty low latency
and good performance even for the
Wrights going all the way to the US so
digging one layer deeper let's again
look at the original configuration first
when you create a cloud spanner instance
as I said you get three replicas
transparently you never know that there
are three replicas in your instance
right you could choose a regional
instance or a multi region configuration
for your instance and the number of
replicas and all that essentially
implementation detail will be hidden
from you what you do is talk to an
instance and a database within that
instance and as I mentioned earlier you
can actually create multiple databases
within a cloud spanner instance if you
need the same replication topology for
them so in this case we have two
databases within the cloud spanner
instance that are replicated across the
three zones that exist for this cloud
spanner configuration so let's look at
the next layer of how rights and updates
work in this configuration so when an
update comes in the system knows so
first of all you're again talking to one
cloud spanner database within a
configuration so you're basically
exposed to one cloud spanner endpoint
for the database you don't ever have to
think about or code in your application
which replicas you should go to that's
not a decision that you have to make
that's something that the system in the
API will take care of which means that
in this case if you're an update comes
in for a table 1 and table 2 so if you
want to update key one and key 2 in
table 1 and table 2 then the API figures
out where the leader of this of these
keys is and will send the request to
that leader so we use Paxos as the
consensus mechanism for our write
commits so there's more information on
Paxos on the link but basically it's a
consensus protocol that says that as
long as a majority of replicas
essentially agree as long as a majority
agrees then you can commit the
transaction or commit data right and so
in this case this is why we have three
replicas so as long as two out of the
three replicas agree on any change then
that change can be persisted so in this
case going back to our example if you
wanted to update table 1 and table 2 as
in key one and key two in table 1 and
table to the protocol will route the
message the request to the leader of the
replica so a leader of these keys need a
replica for these keys and then that
leader is responsible for sending the
request out to the other two replicas
and getting an acknowledgment back and
committing the data and by the time you
get an acknowledgement for that commit
back the data has already been the
mutation has already been shipped out to
the other two replicas so if you do a
read after right
if you make a read request as soon as
you get an update commit acknowledgement
back then you are guaranteed to see the
latest update of the data this is the
the coolness of cloud spanner and its
global external consistency right that
you can actually do a read and after a
committed happened and you're guaranteed
to see the latest data and you don't
have to ever think about whether the
data was eventually consistent which
means that if you ask two different
replicas will you get two different
answers in fact you can ask for the data
from anywhere in the world and you will
get the same answer back guaranteeing
the external consistency that we talked
about now let's get into the more
interesting example of the multi region
configurations and the reads and writes
requests there so starting with the
right request if there's an update to be
made from a u.s. client then basically
the client can just call the API will
route the client request for the right
to the read write quorum which is in the
US and then the request response will be
routed back to the client from the US
right so there's a round trip between
the US client and the u.s. quorum and
back in case there is a client in Asia
and again we have if you remember we
have the read read corpsman in the US
with five replicas across three
different data centers and then we have
read-only replicas in Asia and in Europe
so if you have a client in Asia making a
read/write request as an update request
for the database basically we'll try and
put the request on the Google Network on
a Google front end as quickly as
possible as close to the Asia client as
possible right so within Asia will
basically put the request on our network
and from there it'll be routed to the
readwrite client sorry they read read
quorum in the US and the acknowledgment
will come back to the Asia client right
so the riots as I said are routed to the
US but because we push the request as
quickly as possible on the Google
Network
you know we have guaranteed sort of low
latencies and we have predictable
performance for these requests now if
you make a strong read which is a
consistent read so basically if you
update a key and then you make a request
to read the key from Asia again then
because of this global external
consistency we guarantee that you will
see the latest update in this case so
the important thing to note here is that
the data is being served from the local
replica right the data is not actually
being shipped from the from the US
readwrite form which is an important
distinction because what we're saying is
that as we commit as part of the commit
protocol the leaders actually ship out
the mutations not the data itself but
the mutations to all other replicas and
then the replicas apply the data
themselves right so it's it's lis
distributed system where each replica
acts independently with consensus and
and it's you know making sure that we
get the accurate data and the
consistency guarantees but each replica
is applying this mutation independently
in its own data structures so what that
means is unlike other systems where we
have one master replicas and then the
data is being shipped out to the other
slave replicas in this case all the
replicas behaved is one global database
which means that even though the read
the readwrite quorum exists in the US as
part of committing that right that the
mutations are sent across to all
read-only replicas and then they apply
that the mutations independently and
then the data is served from the closest
healthy replicas to the client making
the request what that means is in this
case the data is being served from the
renal replica in Asia which means of
course it's lower latency and more
predictable performance right so you
don't have to get the data from the US
or from the essentially the quorum in a
different continent right so you're not
shipping huge blocks of data across
oceanic limbs which means you know it
doesn't take as long and therefore we
can have you know better performance
with lower latency this is just one of
the optimization
to be made to both the paxos protocol
and to the entire cloud Spanish stack to
be able to perform these multi region
reads and writes efficiently for the
applications now when you're making a
strong read
there is a ping to the quorum which is
in the US to make sure that the aja
replica has the latest data and knows
what the last commit time for that key
want right so again you're making a ping
round-trip to the US but you're not
actually shipping the data the data
itself is served from Asia now this is
another interesting feature of cloud
spanner that we have these bounded read
requests so because cloud spanner is a
multi-version concurrency control system
it means that we actually maintain older
versions of the data up to a certain
bounded time and if you choose bounded
staleness so if you choose a read
request of a certain stillness of time
then the chances of the data being
served from the local replicas are much
much higher right so you don't even have
to because you're not asking for the
latest data you don't even have to
contact the quorum in a different
continent to ask for what the last
commit time for these keys was right you
can actually just serve the data with
the local from the local replicas
without having that RTT to the leader so
this actually leads to the very low
latency reads from anywhere in close to
all of these multiple regions work for
the multi version configurations right
this is the trade off which gets even
more sort of acute when you look at your
boundedly stale reads and writes right
so the writes will go to the US in this
case to the quorum but the reads
especially stale reads or bounded reads
up to a particular time can be served
from the local replicas so if you say I
want to get the value of these keys like
up to 15 minutes ago up to 15 seconds
ago
you will get the data locally from the
local replicas
right let's get into another layer which
is automatic sharding and life of a
query and how you know what we talked
about at high level like how does it
actually get served from from cloud
spanner so again going back to our
regional picture of three replicas here
we have you know three replicas with the
compute and storage highlighted so when
you provision one node in cloud spanner
it's actually one node per region sorry
one note per availability zone right so
this means that in the regional
configuration you're actually getting
one node in zone a one in node B Zone B
and one in zone C so they're actually
three nodes worth of compute that you're
getting across these three zones and in
this configuration in the picture
we actually have three nodes which is
our minimum for guaranteeing the SLA so
in this case when you sort of provision
three nodes you're actually getting nine
nodes total right which is hidden from
you again you don't have to worry about
the complexity of how these things break
down in terms of provisioning you just
think of you know one node and one nodes
worth of compute for your database and
your instance so as I said storage and
compute are the two axes of cloud
spanner that scale mostly independently
in the storage case we actually shard
the data that's what allows us to be as
scalable as we are and the sharding is
both automatic and it
we sharding happens automatically as
well so the data assignment of a shard
which here in cloud spanner terminology
is a split is done by the system and the
assignment of those shards or splits to
the nodes is also done automatically by
the system so the same shards exist
across all three zones which is you know
where we're getting consistently
sharding the same way across three zones
but the assignment of those shards can
be different depending on the load and
the sort of other workload
characteristics again this entire thing
is done automatically so you don't ever
have to worry about recharging or
rebound
your data so in the regional
configuration let's look at this splits
right so a database has multiple splits
so a database has multiple tables that
have multiple keys in them and basically
a set of keys together is a split right
so we basically are splitting the the
database across a full set of keys and
each split as I said that the splits
happen consistently across the three
zones so each split within one zone is
the same split on the other zones as
well and together they form a Paxos
group and so in this illustrative
example like split one has this one
paxos group across three zones and that
is repeated for all the splits so each
split essentially forms a group along
which we run the Paxos protocol there
are some optimizations here but you know
basic terminology is the same and
basically that's what we're doing so how
are these splits done as I was talking
about earlier basically we have a key
range right a table has multiple keys
and the key space itself is what we're
partitioning right so a database has
tables has keys and those keys have a
key range and each key range forms a
split so in this case if we have keys
from 0 to 2000 as you can see we have 4
splits and the splits don't have to be
even right they can be in terms of the
number of keys it depends on the
workload as I said so if certain keys
are getting more work more queries on
them they have a higher QPS then they
will be put on a separate split because
we do both size based splitting and load
Bay splitting and again this is all
automatic so as load increases load
based learning will split it into
further splits and if there is less load
than the splits will merge to form
bigger splits because you know the nodes
can or the splits
can handle the data sorry the workload
that's coming in so in this case we have
four splits
and each of those splits has a group
with a group leader and as you can see
the split is the same in zone a zone B
and zone C so high level basically we're
saying that each replica has the same
split of data and that split combination
becomes the group and each group has a
leader right and so when reads and
strong reads and writes come in they go
to the group leader who is done
responsible for in the case of riots
from for getting consensus on whether
the right should commit or not and in
the case of strong reads it's
responsible for saying here's the last
update that happened to the split or to
the specific key in the split so again
just to recap we have database with a
bunch of keys which makes the key space
and the spanner spits splits up that key
space into multiple splits and the split
is replicated across all zones within a
instance configuration and each split
group has a leader now again the
important thing to note is that
leadership can also change and is done
automatically based on health and a
bunch of other heuristics and metrics
that we are constantly monitoring so for
for spanner you know changing leader is
not a necessarily a failure only
scenario it's actually done all the time
we're constantly changing the the split
group leader because you know we're
looking at a bunch of heuristics and
metrics and making sure that we can have
the most optimal leadership performance
and which is why we can change the split
leader split group leader on the fly all
the time so now we need to talk about
how these splits are assigned to the
nodes so if you remember our previous
picture right we have nodes that are
compute units that can come and go
essentially and then there's storage
which is the data base and how its split
across with these splits across these
keys but then these splits have to be
operated upon and so they're assign
two nodes within a zone and each zone
assigns splits two nodes independently
based on the health metrics and many
other heuristics again this is done
automatically so if a node goes down
then the split is rebalanced to a
different node or if we just so choose
because of load and other
characteristics we just move splits
between nodes all the time so in this
case you know we're saying the node one
from our three node example in the
regional instance configuration that we
talked about earlier split 0 goes to
node one split one goes to node two and
then split two and three go to node 3
and if conditions are such that we think
you know one of these splits is getting
overloaded then either there'll be a new
split and go to a different node or
split three itself can go to a different
node so as I said you know it's
important to understand that you know a
key range is how we look at spanner
looks at the data in the database as a
key range and we basically split it
across that key range so as I said we
could have multiple splits we don't even
have to have splits matching anything
else though it's not like if you have
three nodes will have three splits we
actually have multiple splits and the
splits can be merged and extracted out
as well so because we look at the entire
database as a set of keys as a key range
choice of key is important and this is
true for basically all relational
databases right because the
relationships are primarily defined
through keys the key choice can
dramatically affect performance for
example if you wanting to query you know
a set of keys or a set of data that is
not in primary key order then you have
to create an index where then the index
keys are in the order in which you
expect to be querying them for faster
response and faster scans right in
general and this is again true for most
databases right you it's recommended to
not use sequential numbers or timestamps
as keys because again
we are splitting up keys and then
sharding the data across the key range
in those splits and then putting the
splits on multiple nodes so if we have
to if you're if you're sequentially
adding numbers or timestamps to your key
range then that means everything in a
particular split in a particular key
range is being affected and that entire
split is being served by a node so
therefore it becomes a hotspot right and
again for for most relational database
so this is a common anti-pattern but
especially for spanner it's it's
definitely not recommended that you
choose your ascending and descending
sequential numbers or timestamps right
so if you need to do that then we
recommend making it you know second
third or fourth part of a composite key
because spanner can take composite keys
so you can actually put these ascending
and descending numbers as a set as a non
first part of the primary key so that we
can split across those and shard the
data so basically when you're designing
your schema you want to think about how
it can be sharded and parallelized
because that's the power of spanner is
to be able to shard and paralyze shard
data and paralyze operations on that
data automatically right so if you allow
the system to split across keys then it
can be better at parallelizing the
workload thereby giving you better
throughput and better performance and
there are more information on this in on
our documentation page on
cloud.google.com slash spanner slash
Doc's slash best practices so life of a
strong read so if you're trying to get
the latest data what happens is your
request goes to the closest replica to
you rate which will look up the split
information and then will ask the leader
what is the latest commit on that data
and then it gets a response back on what
the latest commit timestamp was and then
it will respond with the data at that
time stamp so again to dig deeper right
if we see
read from my table key one two three
then you know the user makes that
request but gets put on our Google
Network Google front end of the cloud
span in front end and then goes to the
zone that is closest to you that can
serve that information and in this case
because it's a strong read as in the
latest data written the request is for
that we have to as I had mentioned
earlier we have to send a ping to the
leader to say okay what was the last
time at at which a data data was
committed for this key and with that
information it can serve the data from
locally to the to the user now the
obvious question here is what happens if
the data hasn't been sent in this case
the mutation hasn't been sent to the non
leader splits which is a great question
what happens is as I said earlier as
part of the commit we're actually
sending out the mutations to all the
other replicas so chances are that it's
already been received by you know split
to zone a in this case and will be
served by the zone a split to to the
requester if it is the case that you
know the zone a split to hasn't received
data at time T bang as is mentioned here
which is the latest timestamp of commit
then there might be a little bit of a
wait to get to that timestamp and then
get the data that times them and then
respond back but as I said in most cases
because we're sending the data out
parallely there shouldn't be
these latencies are generally hidden
within the commit time itself in terms
of a boundedly still read as I talked
about earlier if you make a request for
this key one two three again but with a
maximum 15 second staleness
what that means is we the local replica
is confident that it has the data at
that time the the older you go the more
chances are that this you know the the
mutations have been replicated to the
other
replicas which means that it can serve
this request without even having to talk
to the leader so in terms of single role
rights so basically what this means is
that we're trying to commit data to a
single key or single row in this
configuration in this case it's a three
zone configuration but you know the same
applies to a Multi multi reading
configuration as well so basically the
requester makes a write request and then
the write request goes directly to the
leader and again the API and the and the
system itself know where the leader is
so the write request is directly routed
to the leader the leader acquires locks
that's you know the whole point of
leadership is to to be the sole
proprietor of committing data to those
committing changes to that data and
therefore it has the lock so it'll
acquire their locks and then it will
send the write request to the other
replicas within the quorum in this case
the two other replicas in this
configuration and the replicas will
basically act so it's basically
two-phase commit for the replicas will
accept they're ready to write that they
agree with this proposal and once the
the the split leaders but to leader in
Zone B gets acts back from a majority so
basically from one of the zone in this
case right
two out of three or three out of five
it'll release the locks and it'll apply
the changes locally and then send their
success request back to the to the
requester right so again as I was saying
earlier as part of the commit protocol
the rights are actually mutations are
actually being sent out which means that
you don't actually have to wait for the
data to be applied at the leader and
then have it the data be replicated to
other replicas the mutations are being
replicated as part of the commit and
therefore they're being applied
independently and chances are that if
you read the same data after the commit
response has come back that you will get
the data immediately from the local
replicas
let's look at a more interesting case
which is writing across two different
splits so if you want to write across in
a table or multiple tables which happen
to be on two different splits then those
splits will have to coordinate in order
to commit the right so let's look an
example where we are going to commit
data such that split one and split two
iron bolt as you can see from this
diagram split one is as leader in zones
C and split two has leader in Zone B so
when a write request comes in to commit
data to row x and y as part of that
write request the coordinator is already
chosen by the client which means chosen
by the API itself in this case we have
chosen Zone C leader to be the
coordinator so each of these splits will
acquire the locks for making changes to
row x and y and then they will
independently talk to their replica
across the multiple zones right so at
this point similar to the previous
single row case basically they replicate
the data across the two other zones for
their split and then once they have
received acknowledgments back from those
two other replicated split groups from
their group they will respond back to
the coordinator which is the split one
in zone C to say that they're ready to
commit at that point because split C is
the coordinator it'll basically tell
split two to do the commit of the data
at which point each group leader will
then tell its other replicas to apply
the change and the success is returned
back to the client so in this case the
same protocol that we were talking about
in the single row case happens at each
split level where each split leader
informs its other
does to you know apply the change and to
make the proposal for the change
but then there's coordination among
split leaders on doing the commit for
all the roads that are part of this
commit so I know we covered a lot of
material but hopefully it gave you a
sneak peek at or at least a better
understanding at how cloud spanner works
under the covers to give get external
global consistency stay tuned for a live
Q&A we'll be back in less than a minute
you
welcome back we have a few questions
that we can go over in with regard to
what we just discussed so let's get to
them so first question how does spanner
know which kind of read the client is
asking for and should this functionality
be built into the client so yes the
question was answered basically the
functionality is actually built into the
API where the API knows where to route
the read also the the API itself when
you make a request you can actually when
you are specifying bounded staleness
it's it's part of the call part of the
request that you make is to say that you
know I can tolerate bounded stainless up
to let's say 15 seconds or 10 minutes or
whatever and because of that like it is
a pretty big hint to the API that it
should use the bounded stale read
request instead of a strong read if you
specify nothing and just say give me key
1 value 1 then by default we give you
the strong reads right because we expect
like all databases relational database
to read we expect you to want the the
consistent read answer the most freshest
read that just happened hopefully the
answer is that any plans to have a
standalone simulator to test spanner yes
we have a plan for that basically we're
working on open sourcing our sequel
engine and the the relevant parts of it
that will then allow us to build a
simulator we used locally not on
machines and stuff and you don't have to
constantly be connected to the cloud and
machines and stuff and you don't have to
constantly be connected to the cloud
we're working on it and you know
hopefully we'll have it in soon enough
next question the spanner support column
constraints such as foreign key
constraints so so far I've been support
foreign key constraints in the form of
interleaves tables so basically if you
interleave a table into a parent then
that automatically gives it a foreign
key constraint where you have to have
the parent in order to have the child
well beyond that we don't
have foreign key constraints in the in
the product yet hopefully will we have
it on our back lot and hopefully we'll
have it sometime in the future so that's
all the time we had for questions today
hopefully you enjoyed the talk and stay
tuned for talks coming every Tuesday
from cloud on air webinars from Google
cloud thank you and have a good day